what up guys welcome to the just Hurley
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to 90 Day Fiance one of
the classics I've seen Clips have been
before Big Ed and I forgot the other
girl's name before I start don't forget
to like the video on your way and
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell let's get started I
just traveled 5 000 miles to meet Rose
she's more beautiful than I expected so
we need this bag here
we met online three months ago and we've
been talking ever since
it's always so cute to hear guys be like
oh she's so beautiful I don't know just
I know this is like a very weird
situation and these aren't happy you
know couples and stuff but there's just
something about what a guy's like oh
she's even more beautiful in person
ready let's go but Rose has always
avoided my questions about her past so
now that we're face to face I can ask
her
I'm definitely looking forward to
getting to know each other
oh wow oh nice this is my first time to
smash or past us you Pat okay okay so
two two beers in sober pass but but
drunk smash
he's laughing he he knows when guys okay
what the pro tip ladies when guy says uh
uh it's a yes but they're not proud of
it
all right blessing be real smash or pass
Savannah
I said his girlfriend might be watching
but smashed
thank you so much is my passport
anyways that's your color by the way
Brown no red Brown no Brown's the color
of your skin no you're you're the red
dress okay I'm so excited but I feel no
reviews because it keeps talking to me
and my English speaking is a little bit
and limited but um definitely make sure
it's two beds or my mom will kill me
this is what I mean when I say men
really don't give a about your
personality
I just want you to be nice enough
but it's like they can they can barely
understand these girls but they're nice
they're like oh okay fine
so
um I hope you enjoy your stays thank you
so much okay bye-bye okay
oh nice wow look at this there's only
one bed oh wait a minute they're pushed
together oh you want two beds because um
I want to take it slow okay you're so
sweet yeah I wanna I want you to feel
comfortable that would have humbled me
so fast
swear to God a man takes you to a
five-star hotel and then says I want to
take it slow oh my God and he looks like
that no offense dad but like come on you
know you're punching oh my God bye I'll
be like oh you're so sweet like I would
be humbled I swear to God I would be
humbled I want nothing more than to be
intimate with rose right now but I'm not
really comfortable doing that yet I
still know nothing about her past so I'm
not planning on having sex with rose
until she takes an STD test I want to
know for myself that I can trust her
how do you feel me sitting in front of
you huh I think that's reasonable
actually if it's like a girl you don't
know from another country I think that's
reasonable and you're actually talking
to me is it
okay we live this is real me too I
cannot believe I hear my my face
you know
feeling safety excited oh yeah you
really don't sound excited okay you
don't sound excited because you're tired
yes yeah of course and guess what we're
the same height when I'm sitting down
yeah sure
I'm glad it said to me wants to do bad
because I'm not feel comfortable
there you are awesome how you doing yeah
come this is a person to meet and in a
person so I'm not ready to be intimate
I have no pajamas
I um got you a shirt that you can wear
to sleep in it's really cute
ouch
yes
that's nice is that nice okay so you
wear that and then um my shirt yeah
perfect you're good yeah okay so
it sounds like a lot of work when you
could just date someone in your own
never mind I remember I know that's
that's yo he had another girl after this
yeah he like cheated on her too that's a
mad that like a check mark does wonders
that the sorry guys you can't see off
camera Kobe Kobe said my manager said
who's he gonna date but I'm saying like
this man you should see there's another
episode that I've seen clips from where
he's like cheating on this other chick
yeah yeah Big Ed's got options
apparently blessing you know what I'm
talking about like you should add it to
the list it's always talking it's always
joking always funny so want to sleep
oh I'm exhausted
after seeing Rose for the first time I
definitely think there's chemistry I
know there's chemistry hey Rose you want
to watch TV
but I want to make sure that she really
likes me because my intention when the
time is right is to propose
good morning good morning
[Music]
last night Rose and I spent our first
night together but we did not consummate
our relationship I want to take things
slow with rose because I want to be
respectful but also I want her to take
an STD test first and I've not found the
right time to ask her
foreign
but for the first time in 28 years I
have a girlfriend are you having a good
time 28
[Music]
like the room I like this room
Ed has all the conditioner whole night
I'm still freezing and it's still hot
this is this is crazy
I like it don't get me wrong it's
it's just a lot to take in
[Music]
where are they hi hi do you speak
English does anybody speak English oh
they're in the Philippines okay
oh my God pajamas I think these are
pajamas the fact that Rose doesn't even
have pajamas made me feel really sad so
the first thing I'm going to do is get
her pajamas
yeah
so much
180 pesos
[Music]
you can't just grab from my wallet okay
I want to see how much this is I don't
even I don't even know how much this is
how much 180 awesome if the change
she did not
die she has the audacity oh my God these
women from these no keep the change
thank you okay see this
I'm just in a swarm of hot sweaty people
right now it's probably over 100 degrees
I'm sweating my ass off right now
I want to buy your dress with flowers oh
you want to buy a shirt with flowers
okay okay
you like this I like this one okay so
how much 487 481 how much is that hold
on hold on hold on ah he's like not this
time
I'm not comfortable with um Rose
grabbing my money because that's not
what you do thank you thank you
I think it's borderline you know
inappropriate and I already have
questions about your sister because
you know she asked me for money her
sister texted me the other night she
basically said you know I need help my
store is going to close and she's asking
me for money
oh who is that okay I don't know I don't
want to believe that this could just be
a scam but what do you of course
um
what do you know about you guys but I
feel like okay in life you start to
learn your league right because you'll
go for one girl or guy in my you know in
my case it'll go for someone and you'll
be rejected okay then you go for someone
else that's a little bit lower and you
get accepted and then you go a little
lower and they're so enthusiastic you're
like okay that's that's my league right
you guys are nodding you understand the
game you know you're lit yeah and so I
don't know about you guys but me if
there's a guy that I perceive as to be
you know what actually I'm gonna tell a
story this got me in trouble once now a
couple years ago there was a guy that I
perceived to be too high above my league
and I rejected him because I felt like
he was too hot for me yeah like I just
felt like yeah and it turns out I I
don't know men talk he could have just
been lying but I think he actually would
have dated me and he told me he yeah I
don't it doesn't matter but my point is
I kind of fumbled the bag because he
said he was looking for a wife and he's
like yeah you're just smart yeah yeah I
know I know and I thought I thought he
was too hot but me so but my point is my
point is I feel like if someone comes at
you that's like three four points above
your league you're kind of like what's
the catch what's the catch like they're
like as a woman you're like oh he's just
here for six and as a guy I feel like
you're like oh she's here for my money
or for you know yeah and that's like the
equivalent so I feel like yes it's a
scam
I don't know if Rose is in on it or not
listen I'm dying I'm like so hot right
now
yeah
I'm soaking wet I know I want to go
I am so uncomfortable right now the only
thing I wanted to do was spoil Rose but
I'm sweating like a pig
and I'm upset because Rose is grabbing
my wallet and pulling money out and
handing it to vendors I'm just
I'm done with this right now I went out
of here
I know but I just close I want to go I
need aircon I need air conditioning I'm
dying
sorry no girl wants to be with a guy
that's kind of a when you go
outside oh no it's too hot out oh no
it's like do you know what it's like as
a woman oh my gosh actually I'll give
you a few names in the store there is a
story okay let's just say let's just say
him okay on a trip with my family and
there was um one of the sisters not
gonna name which one brought a boyfriend
okay and this boyfriend couldn't do
and it was like we'd be trying to go
sledding oh no no no no then we try to
go skiing oh no oh you know what that's
like as a woman like we want to be led
we don't want to like be dragging you
I'm telling you guys don't if it's hot
out don't be like you just deal with
that like you don't want your girl girl
to like she was this guy She's Gotta
like teach every anyways you can take
that or leave it okay
you can't even like how is he gonna
protect you if you can't even deal with
the heat anyways let me know what you
guys think in the comments um subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell like the video on your way out and
I will talk to you next time